تتغير الحياه سريعا في مريكل وكان الهول
الذي شهدته المدينه مضى عليه وقت طويل
حمله ترميم واعاده اعمار على نطاق واسع
اطلقتها سلطات الروسيه فور سيطرتها على
المدينه امودم كان لي بيت قرب البحر وقد
احترق بالكامل الان اعيش هنا مع ابنتي بعد
ما حصلنا على شقه
كنا نعيش في القبو مع اسرتين اخرىين انا
سعيده فشقتنا هنا رائعه والاهم انها دافئه
خلال اقل من سبعه اشهر شيدت احياء سكنيه
جديده باكملها تضم نحو 2000 شقه يتم
تسليمها لعائلات شردتها الحرب قد تكون
مريول الاستثناء مقارنه مع العديد من
المدن والقرى في المنطقه فمنها ما هو قريب
من خط جبهتي وتحت النيران ومنها ما لا
يزال تحت سيطره القوات
واخرى تحاول الاستمرار في الحياه رغم
القصف المستمري والخوف
العاصمه كانت احد اهم المراكز الحيويه في
المنطقه كانت هو لم تعد فالقصف الاوكراني
المتواصل حول العديد من احياء المدينه الى
مناطقه شبه مهجوره معظم من بقوا من
المسنين او من الذين قهرتهم الظروف فلم
يتمكنوا من المغادره
من بين هؤلاء الناس احدى ابنتيها تعاني من
انفصام في الشخصيه بعد اصابتها جراء
العمليات العسكريه عام 2015
وحاليا تتلقى العلاج في مستشفى للامراض
العقليه اما ابنتها الثانيه فاضطرت الى
مغادره المدينه بحثا عن العمل لاعاله كل
اسرتها بعد فرار زوجها الى اوكرانيا
لن اذهب من هنا الى اي مكان لقد كبرت على
هذه الارض وهنا دفنت والدي وهنا اربي اح
فادي يعقل ان اغادرها سيهدا الوضع
رغم الانضمام الى روسيا رسميا فان التغيير
قليل فعليا ويدرك الناس انه ماذا المعارك
مستمره فان معاناتهم تستمر وهذا البازار
احد الاماكن القليله التي لا يزال السكان
يترددون عليها
نحن جميعا في خطر وجميعنا يغامروا اتي الى
العمل اقف هنا ولا ادري ان كان المكان
سيؤسف ام لا
لكن الحياه تجبرنا على ذلك
الوضع خطير لكن لابد لي من الخروج وشراء
الطعام
وكما في اي حرب تتجسد الماساه ايضا في
احوال الاطفال الذين حرموا التعليم
والتجوال واللعب يخشى الاولياء على
اطفالهم من الخروج فاغلقت المدارس وباتت
المتنزهات فارغه فمنذ اندلاع الازمه عام
2014 البشر حتى اليوم لقي نحو 130 طفلا
حتفهم جراء المواجهات التي لا تزال مستمره